we're asked to solve the equation two x
squared plus three is equal to 75 so in
this situation it looks like we might be
able to isolate the x squared pretty
simply because there's only one term
that involves the next year it's only
this x squared term so let's try to do
that so let me just rewrite it we have
two x squared plus three is equal to 75
I'm going to try to isolate this x
squared over here the best way to do
that or at least the first step would be
to subtract 3 from both sides of this
equation so let's subtract 3 from both
sides the left-hand side were just left
with 2 x squared that was the whole
point of subtracting 3 from both sides
and on the right hand side 75 minus 3 is
72 now I want to isolate this x squared
I have a 2x squared here so I could have
just an x squared here if I divide this
side or really both sides by 2 and you
think I do to one side after to the
other side if I want to maintain the
equality so the left side just becomes x
squared and the right hand side is 72
divided by 2 is 36 so we're left with x
squared is equal to 36 and then to solve
for X we can take the positive with a
plus or minus square root of both sides
so we could say the plus or let me write
it this way we could if we take the plus
if we take the square root of both sides
we would get X is equal to the plus or
minus square root of 36 which is equal
to which is equal to plus or minus 6 let
me just write that on another line so X
is equal to plus or minus 6 and remember
here if something squared is equal to 36
that something could be the negative
version or the positive version it could
be the principal root or it could be the
negative root both negative 6 squared is
36 and positive 6 squared is 36 so both
of these work and you could put them
back into the original equation to
verify it let's do that if you say 2
times 6 squared plus 3 that's 2 times 36
which is 72 plus 3 is 75 so that works
if you put negative 6 in there you're
gonna get the exact same result because
negative 6 squared is also 36 2 times 36
is 72
plus 3 is 75